okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness introduces some major
variants from across the mcu these are a
superhero group known as the illuminati
who have managed to turn their earth
into a utopia full of free food where
only papa pizza is getting dope god damn
before the movie released they were
easily the most anticipated part of it
and for the best part of the year
everyone was guessing who was going to
be in the lineup this ranged from tom
cruise's superior iron man to jonathan
mages as iron lad and when we got a shot
of professor x's shoulder the internet
went wild we then got a shot of his hand
oh my god his hand captain caught a
shield and though they end up getting
taken out faster than you leave this
video when i bring the puns out there's
still a lot to talk about with them
throughout this video we'll be going
through the entire lineup and also
discussing about how the movie changes
things up from the comics i'll also be
making excuses for the film and why them
being killed so easily is actually
properly thought out rather than them
just being a bunch of chumps so sit back
relax please hit the thumbs up button
and also make sure you subscribe for
videos like this every day without the
way thanks for clicking this now let's
get into the illuminati
illuminati more like suicide squad
okay so the super group first appeared
in the comics all the way back in new
avengers issue 7 which built up to civil
war the aptly titled book wrote a civil
war pretty much recounts the majority of
their interactions and it chronicles the
group throughout the years as they work
from the shadows controlling major
events they were made up of neymar the
king of atlantis tony stark aka iron man
reed richards aka mr fantastic black
bolt leader of the inhumans dr strange
the sorcerer supreme and professor x
leader of the x-men black panther was
also going to be a member but he ended
up stepping away after believing that
their agenda would cause some issues you
pretty much had every aspect of earth
covered in them as you had the
atlanteans people represented in tony
reed showing the science space side of
the superhero community inhumans wizards
and also mutants this meant that they
all had their foot in some part of its
progress and each counted as one vote
for their people forming after the cree
scroll war they were brought together
because tony realized that in not being
united it led to a difficult conflict
each aspect of the group all had their
own set of knowledge on certain parts of
the race but the fact that they didn't
work together meant that the war raged
on when they could have easily stopped
it so together every time there was a
big event in the comics the group would
meet and decide what to do however over
the years they slowly started to
disagree with each other which led to
some internal conflicts arguably the
most devastating point was when the
united to come to a decision over what
to do with the hulk he had just
destroyed las vegas and thus they came
up with a plan to trick bruce into
traveling into space to help defeat a
rogue ai after he completed the mission
they revealed he was too dangerous to
have on earth and they blasted him off
into space they said they'd picked out a
peaceful planet for him to live on but
that was a [ __ ] lie and it was
revealed to be sakura which led into the
events of planet hulk hulk became a
gladiator that then overthrew the
emperor and he ruled the planet
unfortunately his ship exploded and it
killed his wife which made him return to
earth angry on a quest for vengeance
this led into world war hulk which
neymar actually predicted would end up
happening everything came to a head just
before civil war which required
superhumans to register their names with
the government tony correctly predicted
that due to rising tensions amongst
humanity and the heroes that one day
someone would make a mistake that would
cause so much backlash that they'd end
up getting outlawed this indeed happened
and thus to avoid a war tony ended up
becoming the face of the superhuman
registration act however the arguments
over whether this was the right thing to
do or not caused so much tension amongst
the group that they ended up dissolving
they did reform for some major events
down the line but they were never really
the same after this point their
arrogance led to their downfall which is
very much also married in the movie now
it's theory time their time your time
your time your time
one of the big criticisms i've seen
around the film is that retells wonder
black bold's power even though he's
meant to be the smartest man on earth
although he does this because he assumes
that he's dealing with the same wonder
from his reality we know that the one in
their dimension has her kids so she
likely never went through the events of
west view and instead probably had them
by some other means tony also doesn't
seem to be alive in this reality so the
age of ultron we saw didn't really
happen now we do see ultron bots but
these were probably created by reed and
didn't have the personality issues that
tony brought with them therefore because
all that evil ultron stuff didn't happen
vision was likely never created either
thanos was also murdered by the
illuminati on titan so even if vision
does exist then he wouldn't have killed
him in order to get the mind stone so
all the events of west view wouldn't
have happened because this didn't go
down wanda never became the scarlet
witch and also never got the darkhold
therefore her power is probably still
age of ultron level and that's why reed
doesn't see her as a threat in age of
ultron we even saw her struggling to
fight ultron bots at one point which is
likely why they just leave it to them
instead of going straight out when
strange is getting interrogated he even
says she's coming and they're like meh
who gives a
now they have a hubris which makes them
think because they've handled thanos
that they can easily handle wonder which
is why they end up waiting in a divide
like billy big bollocks anyway that's
the end of theory time your time theory
time your time and then line up all
pulls from different aspects of the
marvel universe which i want to go over
for the next part of the video now
firstly we have mordo who replaced
supreme strange as the magic side next
is captain carter whose origin story we
saw and what if she can do this all day
or for about five minutes and no i don't
believe she's the version we met and
what if we have seen our origin story
play out in that show peggy ended up
taking the super soldier serum instead
of steve and when she tackled the giant
octopus beast that was either gargantus
or schuma gorath she was transported
into the present now we know that coda
is going to be back for season two what
if and we also ended with her coming
across a frozen steve rogers along with
black widow either widow fury or hawkeye
or in this universe so i'm guessing that
the what if version is slightly
different and that will instead see
heroic play out in the follow-up next i
want to talk about captain marvel who in
this universe is maria rambo instead of
carol danvers this one is pretty simple
to explain and all it does is involve a
changeup and who took the project
pegasus flight in captain marvel maria
and carol were both called to the base
on the morning of the test run but we
learned that carol took a short cut so
she got there first i think that in this
universe she simply stuck to the main
road and therefore ended up getting
their seconds so maria took it instead
captain marvel also ended up flying into
space with the scrolls at the end of her
first solo movie whereas maria remained
on earth because she had a daughter i
think this will be the same reason that
she's in the illuminati because rather
than going into space she stayed behind
to be with her kid and to protect her
planet next is black bolt who appears in
his comic book acura costume even with
the tuning fork he makes a mind-blowing
appearance and in case you haven't seen
the inhumans the guy's power lies solely
in his voice just in the same way that
cyclops from the x-men shoots
uncontrollable blasts from his eyes when
black bolt speaks it causes devastating
sound ripples to tear apart anything
that's in front of them show me what
that mouth do baby what mouth next is
professor rex who is once more played by
patrick stewart ripped right out of the
90s cartoon he arrives in his yellow
chair along with his green suit x seems
like the usual one that we've
encountered from the fox franchise and
he's way more on stranger's side than
they are being a telepath lets him know
instantly that this version is telling
the truth and he even gives some advice
before attempting to confront wonder now
this may potentially be the version from
the cartoon and we could also discover
his backstory in the upcoming x-men 97
show i know one of the big criticisms
around the movie is that x goes out like
a chump but the guys died loads of times
before so who knows maybe this version
is still alive he of course can also use
variants of him and i do hope that he's
back in a more expanded role in the
future now lastly is reed stretch
armstrong richards aka mr boombastic
tell me fantastic dub this smartest man
on earth reed lives a lovely life with
his wife and his two kids sue sadly has
just become a single mother but at least
they'll be someone to raise them god
damn now this read created the baxter
foundation and with his scientific mind
he's made several advances in technology
that put this earth far ahead of the
616. rediscover teleportation and though
we don't meet the other fantastic four
members they are likely out there now
when we get to the main earth i think
that reed will be a lot younger as we
haven't heard of the character yet he
will likely just be starting out won't
have kids and this reed might be used as
an example to him like the other
strangers are for steven perhaps
knowledge of him will finally allow the
616 read to crack some of the sciences
that lead to his transformation into mr
fantastic but we'll have to wait to see
how it plays out in the upcoming
fantastic ball movie now another big
issue i've seen people have with the
film is that he's meant to be the
smartest man on earth but he's a bit of
a [ __ ] for this i just say being called
the smartest man on earth and actually
being the smartest man on earth are two
different things for example with me i
always get comments where people tell me
to do stuff and a lot of the time in my
arrogance i'm like look mate i've got
over 900 000 subscribers i don't need to
listen to you i know what i'm doing i'm
i'm the smartest youtuber on earth you
see all the time when people get called
stupid that have done something
successful and they're like how can i be
stupid i'm ronald mcdonald with over 1
million restaurants i think it's the
same with reid which is why he
completely ignored strange's warning
that the witch was coming because he
thinks he's the smartest man on earth
that's kind of how i see it and the last
bit of the video where i keep making
excuses for this move two seconds
hey karen
that's that's my wife karen spoilers
karen has the check from kevin feige
cleared yet
yeah cool right as i was saying the last
big criticism i want to address about
the movie is how they were all taken out
within about three minutes and how it's
just a waste of introducing these
characters to kill them straight away
that i'd say i think this was all done
purely to show how powerful wonder is no
matter how good the team is she's
fighting she can kick the crap out of
them if needs be so it just elevated the
threat i am 100 sure that these
characters or versions of them will be
back so seeing them die like this adds
to the danger of their return we now
know they're not invincible so the
stakes will be higher for their solo
movies the fantastic four is of course
in production so yeah reed will be back
we already have a version of captain
marvel the inhumans exists if if you
want to watch that which good luck and
though we don't have an x-men movie
announced you can bet that's coming too
there's also what it for captain carter
so it's not like we'll never see these
characters again like i said i think
this was done purely to build tension
and if you've been following our bits on
the film then you'll know we describe
wonder as being like the terminator i
think the scene is pretty much just the
same as the one in the police station
during the first movie where you think
it's safe oni shows up kills everyone
and shows sarah that not even the
authorities can protect her really nice
way of building the threat up in my
opinion but let me know below if you
disagree now we are in competition right
now and giving away three copies of
spider-man no way home on the 15th of
may and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the illuminati we picked the
comments on that day and the winners of
the last one on screen right now save
that to you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the film which will be
linked on screen right now one of our
funniest videos which
depends what kind of sense of humor you
have as it's all subjective but go check
it out after this as you might learn
something let's be honest mate you
bloody need to because there's 400
marvel movies coming out and you're not
going to have a clue what's going on so
go over there
and say thank you as well i'm just
kidding love you and enjoy the rest of
your week mate take care peace